ah
[Música]
nací en montevideo
y a los cinco años soñaba con vivir el
caribe
mi mamá que era limpiadora le decía a mi
papá que era basurero
que yo había nacido en un repollo como
podía ser posible que una niña de
extracto social tuviera semejante sueño
a los 31 años
fui gerente de un hotel en playa del
carmen
en el caribe
[Aplausos]
qué pasó en todo ese tiempo me encontré
con personas que me brindaron a portu
por favor graben en eso oportunidades
volviendo a mi infancia a los nueve años
desarrolló una enfermedad
en la cual me operan ambas piernas hasta
los 17 años sistemáticamente
cada vez que salía de una de esas
operaciones encerradas las dos piernas
con alambres tenía que volver a aprender
a caminar
tal vez la mayor lección que me dejó esa
enfermedad cuando mira con el diario del
lunes
con dos cosas fundamentales
me ayudó a transitar por mis propias
sombras mis partes oscuras generalmente
uno quiere zafar de eso y las
enfermedades black se la ponen como un
espejo enfrente y eso me ayudó muchísimo
a soltar las adicciones tenía problemas
con
y la segunda cosa en la que me ayudó
fue que me introdujo
invito al camino del autoconocimiento a
través de la meditación
años después persisten un poco los
dolores en las piernas y como una forma
de rehabilitarlas
me encuentro con yoga una herramienta
que realmente
me dio mucho más que rehabilitarán las
piernas hoy corro camino para ti nos
escalo
la sudor principalmente a rehabilitar el
alma
en todo ese proceso estuve en contacto
con diferentes realidades
que fortalecieran los derechos humanos
de los sectores más débiles de nuestra
sociedad
entonces trabajé en hogares infantiles
orfanatos
trabajé en asentamientos con personas en
situación de calle use mi experiencia en
adicciones y trabaje también con adictos
y observé en el trabajo que los papás y
las mamás de saborizada con la gente que
trabajaba principalmente estaba en tres
lugares
pueden hacer el ejercicio de imaginarlo
un hospital
el cementerio
y las cárceles
ya de vuelta en uruguay
en el año diciembre del 2013
comienzo a soñar con cárceles
pero no como ese sueño que les dije
recién de alcanzar algo como ir al
caribe no era ese sueño que uno tiene
cuando duerme entonces me despertaba
angustiada me despertaba asustada
yo me veía en una habitación sucia
hedionda con ruidos estridentes de
cerrojos sentía la presencia de hombres
y entonces me preguntaba durante meses
me siguió ese sueño me preguntaba qué
estoy haciendo
porque conozco lo fuerte que son mis
sueños
hasta que un día me cae
una ficha
la conocí en el año cerca del año 2010
en mexico es la directora de una
fundación que se llama park in a mayorga
tanatóloga psicóloga experta en
adicciones y desde aquel momento ya
llevaba a la práctica de yoga a las
cárceles
ahí supe que lo que el sueño me estaba
revelando no era que iba impresa sino
que el sueño me estaba invitando a que
todo ese aprendizaje que había recorrido
empezarlo a compartir en cárceles me
pongo en contacto con ella después de
años de que la una de la otra no sabía
nada le cuento lo que me está pasando
con la idea de que podamos hacer algo
juntas por el sur cuando ande por estas
latitudes y ella me dice vaya que sí fue
una sorpresa que me dice la semana que
viene estoy llegando a buenos aires unas
semanas después estábamos en la unidad
número 6 de punta de rieles dando el
primer taller de yoga adentro de sacarse
llegaron 30 internos era un número para
ese momento muy muy grande sepan que en
las cárceles sostener un grupo de cinco
seis siete ocho personas es un cupo
exitoso llegaron 30 30 internos burlones
inquietos jamás habían tenido contacto
con la práctica
sin embargo poco a poco empezaron a
conectar con las consignas del taller y
cuando terminó este taller parecían les
digo en serio 30 bulas estaban
conectados con su respiración estaban
conectados con su paz interior
y recuerdo que uno de ellos cuando pudo
hablar
estaba muy emocionado con todo lo que le
estaba pasando abre los ojos húmedos y
dice
nunca pensé
que yo podía sentir esto
dentro de mí
así nace yoga y valores en cárceles del
programa o bihan en abril del 2014
llevamos cuatro años y medio llevando
estas herramientas ininterrumpidamente
estas herramientas de transformación de
la conciencia como una forma de trabajar
atención la seguridad pública para
nosotros la seguridad pública es el
cambio de conciencia no son más rejas no
son más armas es cambiar nosotros y es
el cambio capaz que más duro que tenemos
que hacer porque nos cuesta mucho
mirarnos y más como sociedad
[Aplausos]
culturalmente pensamos que en las
cárceles están la basura social
si diéramos por cierta esa afirmación
no les puedo contar por mi historia de
vida que la basura se limpia
la basura se recicla
la basura se transforma
si tenemos el valor
si tenemos el coraje de no barrer bajo
la alfombra de los juicios y el olvido
ahora les quiero compartir brevemente
cuatro experiencias dos son experiencias
de personas que han pasado y que están
por el programa y dos son de proyectos
federico interno de punta de rieles
estuvimos trabajando con él
fortaleciendo sus habilidades el ama el
rap el canta rap
lo pusimos en contacto a través de un
proceso que iniciamos de más de un año
con dos de los mejores productores que
hay en el uruguay trabaja con rada con
napster hicimos un cd de diez canciones
masterizado en chile se presentó en la
sala benedetti de agave hoy es el primer
privado de libertad que tiene derechos
de autor por sus obras y recientemente
hace muy poco tiempo creo que fue en
agosto estaba de viaje
estuvo haciendo su primer show en una de
las salas más importantes que tiene
nuestro país en el teatro solís
césar
23 años privados de libertad
hace un año y medio que salió liberado
y que está trabajando fuertemente en su
reinserción social no tiene ni idea de
cuánto porque no vuelve al delito
en esta foto está acompañado por emilio
velázquez empresario empresario
ejecutivo de angela asociación de
jóvenes empresariales del uruguay saben
por qué
recibimos un reconocimiento en ecuador
como uno de los mejores 500 proyectos
para américa latina' de cambios sociales
césar el expreso junto con el empresario
viajaron a ecuador para representar al
programa
pudo subir por primera vez a un avión
volar
viajar conocer otra cultura tener la
responsabilidad
de representar a un colectivo
y hoy vuelve a las cárceles a contarles
a sus compañeros que hay otro techo
posible
experiencias el banco laboral
muchas veces salía de la cárcel con
mucha angustia de ver alumnos que
realmente estaban haciendo un cambio
verdadero y que al salir
2 no la sociedad no les da una
oportunidad esta angustia me la llevaba
a mi casa y cree con esa angustia el
banco elabora el banco laboral de un
programa de yoga imagínense una raya
todo el mundo hasta hasta que por la
perseverancia toque toque toque toque
toque puertas y llegó a la cámara de
comercio española me abre sus puertas y
presentó este proyecto con ellos y
varias autoridades en donde estamos
buscando que empresas hagan alianzas con
el programa para que podamos brindar
trabajo a aquellas personas que salen
liberadas y evidencian un verdadero
cambio
estamos actualmente por firmar la
séptima empresa
mi rango en ese momento pensé que iba a
ser un éxito si firmábamos con 10 porque
las empresas te preguntan y qué nos das
a cambio tienes algún tributo las hago
algún descuento te ayuda y gobierno
tenés algún descuento en finanzas y no
no tenemos nada solo las ganas de hacer
las cosas correctas
yo no cobro un peso por hacer eso ni le
cobramos un peso a la persona que
contratan solo los limpiamos porque
consideramos que eso es lo correcto
el segundo
emprendimiento en el que estamos
actualmente y necesitamos ayuda mucha
estamos construyendo en este momento la
primera escuela para la transformación
de la conciencia dentro de una unidad
qué significa eso que va a haber un
espacio en donde se van a dar materias
como el amor la amistad la colaboración
meditación se van a acercar estas
herramientas a personas que por su
historia de vida crean mente porque
aparte ya les conté mis orígenes de lo
que les estoy hablando no tuvieron esas
herramientas
para cerrar me gustaría irme con la
esperanza de que todo esto que he ido
exponiendo de mí misma y de este trabajo
nos ayude a despertar conciencias nos
ayude a despertar conciencias para
formarnos como personas íntegras capaces
de construir comunidades pacíficas
que valoren y prioriza en el bien común
el bien común antes del egoísmo del
abandono y de la producción
agradezco infinitamente a todas las
personas que vieron algo especial en mí
lo vieron incluso antes de que yo lo
viera
gracias a eso hoy puedo ser la mujer que
mi niña soñó y hoy el caribe lo tengo en
mi corazón cada vez que una de estas
personas regresa al mar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
ah